I'm Catherine Rey I'm 17 and I graduated
with my bachelor's of Science in
computational physics I'm going to fix
everything that's wrong with wheelchairs
I named my wheelchair prime PR personal
robot III it's a triple phase wheelchair
and Emmy showing that it's customizable
to each person's mobility needs I would
consider myself more of an adult than a
child I started attending University
when I was 13 I think that age doesn't
matter what matters is that I work hard
to deserve the opportunity after I
receive it if you're a woman in
technology and you feel that you're
struggling first recognize that your
gender really does not matter and second
of all gain people's respect by working
hard I came to the Bay Area this summer
and started talking to the fellows and I
realized that all of the clerks that
have been seen as bad back home were
embraced my intense passion about doing
things and talking about science that
aha moment happened to me when I came
out here and I was so happy and I felt
that I finally found my people
you